The man sprinted through the hallways of Site-01
as fast as he could.
Bullets whizzed over his shoulders as panicked
shouts went up all around him.
The whole facility was bathed in red as the
security alarms deafened his ears.
He had to move fast, had to get out of here
before it was too late.
A force smacked him in the back so hard that
he fell onto his face, skidding across the
vinyl floor.
Planting both hands on the ground and trying
to push himself back up, he felt his right
shoulder blade creaking and bending against
itself.
He'd been shot enough times in his life to
know what a bullet-shattered bone felt like.
Trying his best to ignore the pain washing
through his body, he kept running.
More bullets hit him.
In his torso, his shoulders, his arms, and
his neck.
One even caught the top of his skull, slicing
a clear line through his hair, but he kept
on running.
The doors were slowly closing in front of
him as the Foundation personnel swarmed the
hallways.
All he had to do was make it to those doors,
slide through the gap, and he'd be free.
If only they could understand.
If only all the agents, researchers, and the
Overseer Council could make sense of what
he was telling them.
They would let him go through those doors
instead of trying to shoot him down like a
dog.
Just 10 feet to go, he was nearly there, when
a bullet ripped through his calf and sent
him tumbling to the ground again.
But this time, before he could get up, a rain
of bullets washed through his body, igniting
a pain so fierce that he wished it could all
just be over.
But it never was.
The pile of pitiful remains was wheeled back
into a containment cell with the door locked
behind it.
You would think the body lying on the floor
was some kind of roadkill, but it was a man.
A man whose body slowly and painfully, over
the course of four months, pushed every one
of the 247 bullets out of itself and got to
work stitching itself back together, as he
lay there weeping on his own.
*
Andrea Twain had been headhunted by the Foundation
while she was still in college.
Sitting in a Harvard library, she'd been hard
at work on her thesis, pouring hour after
hour into researching jellyfish.
She was starting to see them in her sleep,
and she was falling asleep at her desk quite
a lot.
Fueled by energy drinks and cups of coffee,
it was starting to seem like the jellyfish
were floating all around her between the bookshelves.
That's why when she was approached by Foundation
operatives offering her a place studying the
most top-secret entity on the planet, she
was pretty sure it was all in her head.
But then, six months later, and living in
a facility that she didn't even know the location
of, it started to dawn on her the gravity
of the task she had been handed.
Her research topic had been the hydrozoan
Turritopsis dohrnii, a small jellyfish with
the power to reverse the aging process, dubbed
the Immortal Jellyfish.
She had been right on the verge of cracking
what it was about this creature's genetic
makeup that made it able to produce cells
younger than those they were replacing, a
feat that could cure all number of human diseases
and revolutionize medicine and society as
we know it.
But standing at the window in Site-01 and
looking through the glass at SCP-001, Andrea
realized that all of her research had barely
scratched the surface of what was possible.
On the other side of the window sat SCP-001.
To many, this SCP was probably very disappointing
to look at.
It wasn't a giant reptile, it couldn't teleport
around the facility, it didn't have any visible
powers, or really anything to distinguish
it from any of the researchers sitting on
the other side of the glass.
It looked entirely like a regular human male.
It was housed in a standard humanoid containment
cell with no added security features.
It was sustained on a standard humanoid meal
program, three square meals a day with the
correct number of calories, nutrients, and
vitamins.
If anything, SCP-001 probably had a more balanced
diet than Andrea herself did.
Some researchers have questioned the need
for feeding this SCP.
It was immortal, totally unkillable, and resistant
to aging.
It had been burned alive, drowned in acid,
and beaten to a pulp, and yet very slowly,
it would always recover.
So why did they feed it?
If they didn't, it would get quite grumpy.
More than anything in the world, Andrea was
desperate to talk to it.
Containment procedures were very strict around
this SCP.
There was to be no contact beyond the delivery
of meals, no conversations, no sign language,
nothing.
It would sit in itself alone in silence, and
three times a day, a meal would be placed
in front of it by a researcher who would promptly
leave.
The reason?
SCP-001 could predict the future.
Initial research into this SCP found that
it had an uncanny ability to describe events
that had not yet occurred, despite having
no exposure to the outside world.
It could predict an entire season of Major
League Baseball, right down to the individual
player performances.
It foretold the fall of the Berlin Wall, the
Chernobyl meltdown, 9/11, the crash of the
housing market, and countless other events.
In 2004, a careless researcher asked SCP-001
what the weather was looking like.
SCP-001 proceeded in detail to describe Hurricane
Katrina, from its formation through to the
humanitarian response and the political fallout,
a full year before any of those events unfolded.
The Foundation has tried and failed to use
these future predictions in order to prevent
tragedies from occurring.
But due to ironic twists of fate, any attempts
to prevent these predictions from coming true
often wind up fulfilling them.
In the case of Chernobyl, agents who were
deployed into the Soviet Union to work in
the power plant itself wound up making critical
blunders that led to the reactor's meltdown.
If the Foundation had not gotten involved,
the accident would have been averted.
That said, taking a passive approach does
not appear to be an effective countermeasure
either.
It seems that whatever SCP-001 predicts, that
course of history becomes inevitable.
How could you not want to talk to such an
entity?
As Andrea stood at the glass watching it,
she knew she had to hatch a plan.
The Foundation may not be able to prevent
these tragedies from occurring, but surely
they should want to know what's going to happen.
They were researchers, after all, and their
job was to discover information.
Predicting the future?
That was the most valuable information of
all.
But it went deeper than that.
If anything, the predictions of the future
were a byproduct in Andrea's mind.
There was something suspicious going on with
this SCP, something that the Foundation was
trying its best to keep under wraps.
She had seen it in the classified documents,
files left out on desks that should have been
locked away securely.
Security and procedure had grown lax with
the monotony of containing this SCP.
In these files were interview snippets, a
chance for this SCP to reveal who it truly
was.
*
At the start of the first interview, Dr. Lynch
simply pleasantly greeted SCP-001.
He replied: “Your daughter will be hit by
a bus before her 7th birthday.
I can tell you the specific day if you like.”
The interview session was paused as Dr. Lynch
grew distressed and had to leave his post
to go and spend time with his family.
The interview resumed under Dr. Goldstein,
who asked SCP-001 why he felt the need to
give such distressing information to Dr. Lynch.
He replied: “I have told you people countless
times before, you are not to refer to me as
SCP-001.
I am the Founder of this organization, and
you will address me as such.”
When Dr Goldsteined questioned that assertion,
SCP-001 replied:
“You really don't believe everything they
have on file, do you?
Address me as Founder, or I will tell you
about what your husband is up to, Dr. Goldstein.”
Things collapsed very quickly after that.
*
Andrea's plan started, as so many great plans
do, with her sprinkling a chemical compound
over one of her colleague's Cheerios.
It was nothing poisonous, well, at least not
that poisonous, but it would put him out of
action for a few months.
Long enough for her to assume his position.
Andrea had been next in line for a while to
take over the role of meal deliveries for
SCP-001, and as her fellow researcher violently
vomited into a bucket in the corner of their
office, she knew that her time had come.
With the plastic tray in her hands, loaded
with some kind of beige slop and an apple,
she waited in the doorway, ready for the seals
to hiss and the door to slide slowly open
for her.
She stepped into the room, trembling.
She had expected the air in here to be stale,
breathed and re-breathed for decades by the
same man.
But of course, it had been expertly filtered
and purified by the Foundation systems.
The air in here was as clean and balanced
as it had been on the other side of the glass.
The Founder looked up at her as she walked
towards him.
She would be a new face to him, something
he hadn't seen for the prior five years.
His eyes dug into her, showing no surprise
at all.
She suddenly realized that, of course, he
wouldn't be shocked to see someone new.
He could see the future.
He knew that she was coming.
Suddenly unsure of herself, she wondered what
else he knew about her future, about her most
closely guarded secrets, about whether her
plan would work at all.
Andrea placed the meal in front of him silently,
knowing that the cameras and microphones were
all paying close attention to her.
Subtly as she could, she nodded at SCP-001,
turned around, and left the room.
Andrea's heart hammered as she sat back down
on the other side of the glass with her colleagues.
Her entire plan hinged on one thing: monotony.
All of the checks, all of the vigilance, all
of the scrutiny that had been poured into
SCP-001 for decades had to have faded by now.
Faded just enough for the person watching
the security cameras not to notice one word
etched into the plastic tray as SCP-001 took
its spoonful of food.
'NOW'
SCP-001 launched from its chair and sprinted
towards the door in the corner of the room.
Before any of the other researchers could
react, Andrea slammed a hand on the open door
button.
There was a hissing sound, and the SCP was
free from its containment cell.
Confused voices filled the room, yelling over
one another in utter confusion.
They had all been so caught off guard that
none of them had paid attention to what had
just happened.
Before they had time to put the pieces together,
Andrea was out of the door herself, running
down the corridor.
There was just one door between her and the
SCP.
She ran over to key in the security code to
open the door and let the SCP out.
But before she could even touch the keypad,
a bullet caught her in the chest, and she
collapsed to the ground, wheezing.
A scared security agent stared at her wide-eyed.
"What have you done?" he exclaimed.
Then, both of them turned to look at the locked
door, waiting.
*
Andrea Twain had not wanted to let the SCP
out until she saw one specific line from an
interview tape.
SCP-001, referring to itself as the Founder,
explained in patient detail how it was entirely
supportive of the Foundation's goals, motivations,
and actions.
It had no intention of intervening with any
of their work.
It explained that all of their ideals were,
in fact, its own, as it was the one who had
created the Foundation in the first place.
But there was something coming.
A prediction that SCP-001 refused to speak
out loud under any circumstances.
It had just one request that it would repeat
to every interviewer for decades after decade:
they had to free it so that it could prevent
this event from happening.
It must be allowed to construct a device;
otherwise...
well, it never actually explains that part.
It neither does it explain what this device
is and point blank refuses to allow another
to build this device in its stead.
Due to the unpredictability of what would
happen if SCP-001 was allowed to construct
this device, the Overseer Council has point-blank
refused to entertain the notion.
But Andrea just couldn't shake it from her
mind.
This SCP was capable of accurately and precisely
predicting all number of future events, right
down to the granular details, no matter how
tragic and how dark.
Yet, there was an unknown in its future.
It didn't know whether it would be released
or not; it had to beg for its freedom.
Whatever it needed this device to defeat was
clearly so powerful that it went beyond SCP-001's
capacity to predict and understand it.
There was an event coming that was so significant
that it created chaos and uncertainty in SCP-001's
perfect view of the future.
And there was only one entity that Andrea
trusted to be powerful enough to counteract
this event.
And as she lay there dying in a pool of her
own blood, she looked up through the glass
window in the door at the entity she trusted
and watched as it keyed in the passcode to
the door.
The door slid open, and the SCP took off running
along the hallway.
With her dying breaths, Andrea told the SCP
the passcode to the door that it had just
opened, understanding the brilliance of what
had just happened.
The SCP had been able to open that door because
it had seen the future where she told it the
password.
And with that, she smiled and laid her head
down on the hard floor.
*
Except SCP-001 did not manage to escape.
It was gunned down in the hallway with 247
bullets that brutalized its body and wheeled
back into its containment cell, where it began
the slow process of healing.
For most of the research team, things went
back to business as usual, albeit with slightly
better security.
But to the handful of researchers who really
thought about what had happened, a sense of
unease settled on their shoulders.
SCP-001 would have known before it ran out
of that cell and attempted Andrea's plan that
its escape was going to fail.
It would have known decades prior the exact
positions of the 247 bullets that pounded
into its body.
It would have known the searing agony that
it was to endure for months as its body slowly
healed from its failed escape attempt.
And yet, it had gone through with it anyway.
What set of events had been put into motion
when Andrea carved those three letters into
the plastic tray?
What greater purpose was SCP-001 working towards?
And was it now too late to stop it?
Now check out “SCP-001 - 15 Files Protected
By A Memetic Kill Agent!” and “SCP-001
- YOU Are The Anomaly!”